12 Lego sets 24 hours one man can he
build them all in just one day probably
not but I'm still gonna try over the
past couple of years I've been
collecting every Star Wars Lego helmet
as they've been released and with my
wife out of town until tomorrow I've
decided to get them all built while
she's gone and place them around our
meticulously decorated living room but I
really want to surprise her with this so
I have to get all 11 helmets and the
bonus mystery set built before she gets
back tomorrow and to do that we need to
go shopping here they are
damage okay I need to quit buying Lego
sets this entire collection cost around
a thousand dollars so please hit
subscribe so I don't go bankrupt anyways
we only have 24 hours so let's get to
building I have to start with my
favorite Clone Trooper Captain Rex the
obvious choice this collection is called
the Lego Star Wars helmets collection
and it's made up of 11 helmets of
popular Star Wars characters as well as
one additional set that I'll show you
near the end what's really about these
sets is that a lot of the pieces are
actually on hinges and they fold in on
the set and it just makes it so that a
little bit more Dynamic like these
pieces fold down into there pretty cool
liking it so far as I was working on
this first set I started to do some math
I figured that if I could complete each
set in about an hour each I should be
able to get them all done in time and
still be able to sleep tonight
okay Rex took me about two hours and 15
minutes definitely not fast enough to
get them all done in time so let's pick
up the pace for Darth Vader next
at this point I think I was lying to
myself thinking I'd be able to get them
done in time but I really wanted to
challenge myself and get them all built
before my wife came home
[Music]
in case you couldn't tell I'm sitting in
a very uncomfortable chair
[Music]
okay Vader took me two hours and 24
minutes which means at this pace even if
I build throughout the night I won't get
it done before she gets home which means
I'll need to call in some reinforcements
this is Kaden
[Music]
and this is Tyler
with this hand-picked team of Lego
building experts ready to go it was now
time to start the building frenzy one
two three
these helmets are really challenging to
build but it's also pretty rewarding it
may sound silly but I'm actually proud
of myself for sticking with it and
seeing all these builds through to the
end I'm excited to be building these
Lego Star Wars helmets I've been a fan
of the series since I was just a little
kid and I've always loved the look of
the helmets building these helmets is a
great way to connect with your inner
child it's like you're transported back
in time when you were just a kid playing
with Legos all day long I really like
how these helmets look too they're so
detailed and accurate and I can't wait
to display them in my living room okay
we didn't get all the sets done before
they had to leave but when I woke up the
next morning I still had two hours until
my wife got home and all I had to do was
finish the bonus set the Imperial probe
Droid
[Music]
and with that they were all finally done
but there's no time to spare my wife
will be home any minute now so I need to
find good spots for all these sets Boba
Fett first
[Music]
now that I'm doing this I just realized
it might not be a good idea to put these
in the living room since I have a
toddler
oh well
rex on his own little pedestal
this one's super delicate oh oh God it's
breaking it's gonna go right in the
entryway
okay I think we're all set
she's here hi
how's it going
did you notice anything different
got some Legos yeah yeah I did you think
that's what's home yeah yeah that's
where it belongs
oh my gosh got them all that's not
staying there
the Stormtrooper is pretty good well
they're actually I mean they're really
cool I think so I think my favorites the
Storm Trooper and the Manila we're in no
that's
right yeah yeah whatever okay it's like
the same can they stay
[Applause]
please
[Music]